you know you did this interesting thing
you very funny comedian and you did this
set where you were talking about
I guess ways right you had it a comedy
idea which is ways that you could rob
target and so is that right and I wanna
I want to apologize to the people at
Target because I see that this is
getting out of hand this is a real thing
that there's a real thing you can look
it up but I said on my special I said if
you ever want to steal out of target
it's easy all you got to do is wear
reassuring some khakis and then you can
go yeah and still baskets and stuff yeah
well people are doing that now and no
and not just people are doing it a lot
of people were doing a lot of people are
doing in that show they pretty much told
people how to rob one of the biggest
stores in America and now a lot of
people were doing it yes one guy went
with a gun and took like a hundred
thousand dollars from Walmart and I was
like that defeats the whole purpose of
having the outfit yeah yeah yeah you're
just mad that they didn't follow through
with your comedy idea correctly that is
like pearls it works with everything you
know there was I saw footage of one
woman went in and she stole $40,000
worth of cellphone 40,000 yeah target
and they show her and she's wearing the
outfit that you told her to wear and she
walks right out with $40,000 $1000 on
her car I know and I felt bad about that
but a little bit inside I went you're on
to something
kind of a gene tournament genius yeah a
little mastermind of a mastermind yeah
yeah no you should get a little piece of
this that's all I'm saying these pants
are amazing by the way
thank you are these around the office I
did I just won when I got off yeah I
went in the bathroom and put them on I
thought you meant you wore like other
pants over those sometimes know where
I'm going I just thought you were really
heavy that'll Saturday night oh really
yeah without experience
[Laughter]
you